[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
what's going on you guys
addict here Laura coming at you with
another
attic show we talk about the past
present and future game I got my calls
with me durgy what's going on dirt
what's up what's happening what's up man
how you feeling
uh goes by Tokyo I've been playing that
um
that's really all I've been playing
right now trying to focus on that
that's about it man yeah people in the
comment section said I haven't recovered
from a seven hour podcast you are
correct I haven't yeah man I couldn't
believe it
I said holy spot yo oh man it happens
you know I I
I try to
I'm gonna make sure it doesn't happen
again
but you know we got the 300th episode
you know it is what it is uh it was mad
long but at the end of the day you guys
enjoyed it you know I enjoyed it even
though it was long I was just tired
you'd be surprised at how just sitting
around watch it like
talking on a show mentally and
physically drains you yeah it does yeah
and then by the end of that Seven Hour
podcast I was done like I it was 7 hours
and 38 minutes
yeah I was I was done we'll see 30
minutes of it was just like that oh the
screen oh yeah yeah the starting soon
screen you know I got people coming
because I tried to get you to do it but
you didn't see you seemed like he was
busy that day so I wasn't really gonna
yeah man I mean you can ask me as the
last time I was kind of like um then I
actually had a little short time to come
through but I was kind of like man they
already swamped bro you know I had to
send a Super Chat and keep it moving
yeah the we were like an hour of super
chats you know love all the support we
got but damn I was like can they please
stop please hey dude the IOP Community
to be Savage sometimes sometimes they
will literally keep us in there reading
super chats and Super Chat messiness
saying we're holding you hostage
and so you know we got a pretty good
show for you guys going on today
we're gonna talk about uh the
PlayStation Under Fire apparently now it
looks like um
government officials of uh United States
are actually starting to ask you know
FTC yo why you why you simply for
PlayStation what's going on
you know I got to know why you simping
so we see that going on we also see
you know so some Xbox game weeks I don't
know if you've seen those I've made a
couple videos about them I don't know if
you've actually seen the the leaks and
apparently say goodbye Angry Birds or
whatever that franchise is called they
bought the company that owns them I
think I don't think they just bought
Angry Birds I think they bought the
whole yeah they bought the whole company
yeah and which is kind of interesting
because
you would never really think
that that
they they have that kind of money you
know what I'm saying
you would never think they have that
kind of money like the second yeah
I do not think Sega had it like that so
I think it's safe to assume that like
look like just because we think they
ain't in this like they kind of in like
it kind of makes me think that
if they dropping billions like that on
Angry Birds is Microsoft buying them
even like realistic you know what I'm
saying like
I mean I mean yeah I mean I'm I still
think my
Microsoft would drop a bag on them and
you know I don't know man it's very
interesting
yeah so and then you know we're going to
talk about
maybe some extra stuff I started to name
it in the tile uh in the time stamps
extra tiles just depends on what goes on
you know sometimes we'd be doing some
super chats and uh someone bringing for
good little conversation so we uh detour
so right now
appreciate everyone coming through here
you know I think we're gonna go ahead
and start on the second thing because I
think that's the less relevant thing
going on right now you know Sega
Sega has always been a company to me
that they're just there you know they're
making games they're there but I've
never seen them
in that kind of space and it's
interesting that they bought Angry Birds
because back in the day like what 10
years ago Angry Birds was that thing it
was everywhere
all right and it was what's interesting
is the fact that they bought that maybe
because of Sonic they're looking to go
more into animation like you know uh
movies TV shows hey they already had the
Angry Bird movies though I believe I
don't think it did too well
they definitely had an Angry Birds movie
yeah yeah so it's it's going to be
interesting you know what they do with
that IP what was your thought process on
that when you saw that because I know
that's not it's not realistically big
but I think to me
considering what we know of Sega that's
bit in some way
yeah man my first reaction was Sega got
775 million like that that's the first
thing I thought but look man it's um I
get into the mobile world right
uh but getting into the mobile market I
think it's smart at this point the
mobile market makes billions of dollars
a year
I know Angry Birds isn't Papa like it
used to be popping but I mean I'm not
sure what else was a Rovio owns a Rovio
I don't know how to pronounce the um
name of the company but um I mean smart
man I mean get it to the mobile because
maybe
console game it only isn't that you know
great anymore just being only in console
gaming
maybe you need to kind of you know
spread your wins kind of how that
Microsoft is doing you know Microsoft is
about to get into the mobile gaming
space also so yeah I think it's cool man
we're gonna get into that here later on
today it's just it's interesting that
Sega is able to make that kind of
acquisition but they don't really make
moves in gaming too much you know what
I'm saying yeah and maybe it's not
necessarily Sega it's the company who
owns them I think Sammy owns them so
maybe that's where the money came from
but it's just like you know what they
might do with that if it was Sammy that
might make gambling machines with the
Angry Birds
like symbols or something like that
I guess because I know they're real big
into that like making gambling machines
yeah
I mean I guess that's possible I don't
know if that's that would be a big money
maker you know what I'm saying
it just I guess it depends
on what they're trying to do with the IP
is it more gaming Centric is it TV movie
Centric is it you know
stuff like gambling because uh Sammy
owns that kind of uh that kind of trade
I'm just curious what's gonna happen I'm
just man they already come with the
Super Show let me get these you got the
two dollar secret for the you know I got
a soul you know I got soul I probably
butcher that we're good
do something with those beards your
pieces of [__] damn like look man my
beard is magnificent okay
well I don't need that negativity in my
life my beard is magnificent
gotta find out super jump from uh from
Jay all this Xbox Doom and Gloom trash
Microsoft's spending 70 billion on ABK
Microsoft isn't going anywhere you know
we might yeah we might talk about that
too five dollar Super Chat from the
angry therapist Sega giving us the mush
up no one asked for yeah I agree you
know and I think
that's what's so confusing is why they
feel like
pursuing Angry Birds is worth billions
of dollars well close to billions I
think it was in the end like 700 million
so it's like
is why you could have invested that into
your Studios
why is this feel like the go maybe it's
maybe it's they feel like there's a
market to be made and they end up may
cost them a lot of money
it's it's hard to tell man it's hard to
tell I just I it'd be interesting what
they do with it that's for sure yeah I'm
but I am kind of surprised that they did
make a purchase like this okay
now the next step is um what are they
gonna do with it are they going to leave
it the same
you know are they going to add Sonic and
Knuckles as characters and Angry Birds
you know what are they gonna do with it
you know
okay so actually me looking at this
um I'm gonna
probably make a video about this
tomorrow so we'll go ahead
and do one of those extra tiles it's
gonna be after the second topic
um XBox is stopping Twitter support
yeah I saw that
uh hi okay so let me
this is very interesting I I okay
obviously it's it's over money
yep
Twitter support
so pretty much what this means let me go
ahead I think we we only was on that
let's do six minutes for the uh second
one and this one is 15 30.
so all right for those of you that don't
know
Elon Musk Twitter I'm sure everyone here
knows this I mean it's it's been very
very vocal at this point and he's been
making a lot of changes over there at
Twitter and one of the changes he just
made recently apparently is I guess it
was neither a severe discount or free
where these companies could use
the back end of Twitter and and do
things but it looks like it's going to
start cost the money and companies like
Microsoft has said it was starting at
forty two thousand dollars a month
uh so Microsoft just kicked the whole
feature out the door
what I want to hear from you
dirt is do you think
this was worth not having a Twitter
integration or do you think Microsoft
should have paid that
ah well I guess I don't know all the all
of the details of what you know what
they were using it for was it just
advertising I like this is Microsoft not
Xbox right this is Microsoft as a
company right
um
who am I to say what was if 42 000 a
month is worth it for them obviously
they have it
but maybe they have an alternative I
don't know you know um
starting at 42 000 a month man that's
crazy bro um
I don't know the only thing I can say
attic is is it it's obviously it's
obviously not worth it for them I mean
for whatever reason they don't feel
forty two thousand dollars a month is
worth
you know Twitter I guess at this point
so so like they'll have still have a
Twitter but they won't advertise certain
stuff is that well that's what's going
on the way that I read it is they'll
still be present on Twitter it's just
advertising to a degree is going to be
cut back it does look like you know you
know how like you push Xbox share on
Xbox it shares to Twitter that's gone oh
got you um I think that's a mistake I do
yeah I think that yeah you know
Microsoft hasn't been the greatest when
it comes to advertising in general and I
get it they haven't really had so much
to advertise currently I do think they
plan on ranking that up when you start
seeing Starfield redfall I mean we've
seen a decent amount of redfall
advertisements
um once we start seeing fable
you know what damn sure once Call of
Duty starts popping up because that deal
is pretty much going through it this
time and to me
I feel like that Twitter
that Twitter integration of anyone
that's on Xbox Live you never share
straight to Twitter
if that's one of the things leaving is
worth that 42 G's by itself because I
agree with you on that that is free
promotion
every day
and to me it's not even about not having
that free promotion two dollar from
Robert kellett Xbox using Myspace and
Facebook yeah it's not even about using
that free promotion now
because it to my knowledge right now now
it might change because uh you know
apparently this has been a new thing
Sony's still paying that money
so what are you just going to be able to
not share on Xbox or Twitter but you
could share on X uh on you could share
to Twitter on Playstation that's gonna
be a bad look
yeah it's oh yo you know I wanna because
not to mention like the the DVR has been
kind of underwhelming for a while now
and now
what's the point what's the point in
Saving stuff if you can't save it on
social medias and I get it people are
like oh addict first off you can't go to
YouTube
you already you've never been able to
integrate to YouTube like that I
remember they used to let you share
videos to YouTube but I think they turn
that off you've never been able to live
stream to YouTube not one time the
entire time Xbox One never had that
integration but now you're taking off
Twitter just a bad look look I get it
money-wise to me
I ain't using it like that because I
have uh like a 300 capture card I prefer
to use that because it's got better
quality than the DVR that's on Xbox
but I'm a content creator I'm an
influencer I think I'm the exception
there's more people that would use that
than me
and you know
it's just frustrating because it's like
how many times have you popped on
Twitter
and you see that hashtag Xbox share
feature
that's gone that's gonna be leaving if
this is right we don't know I don't
think nothing's been officially
confirmed
but we don't know
I personally feel like
that is a that's an L because now you're
not going to be able to share anything
on Twitter you can't share anything on
YouTube because there's no feature on
that
and people it's like I said people on
Facebook this is not no one shares that
stuff on Facebook no one shares that
stuff on any other let's be real here if
you're not sharing your stuff on Twitter
you are probably over the age of 50.
so that's the the younger audience the
audience they want they're on Twitter
they're not on Facebook you know uh
people millenniums uh higher generation
millenniums and the generation above
that like myself you know I'm a I'm a
early Millennium like we're using
Facebook
but I can guarantee you my brother uses
Facebook to talk to to talk to me that's
about all he doesn't use Facebook like
that I have a cousin doesn't even use
Facebook at all he's always on Twitter
or Instagram and now guess what
it's gone
and I think that's gonna be a problem
because now when Starfield
was live now remember when elder and
ring popped off and it was doing really
really well you saw so many Xbox shares
because there was a game like Elden ring
that helped you push that narrative
because you had a place to push it out
but now when Starfield comes out you're
not going to have that feature if this
is true
so my question to them is who's doing it
then
no one
now um you're gonna have a scenario
where multi-platz
like Call of Duty you know Dead Island 2
you're gonna have scenarios where these
games
are being shared by PlayStation users on
Twitter or not Xbox so it's going to
look like it's an exclusive and it's not
yeah I mean
yeah I didn't think about it like that
the Xbox share feature I'm I'm sure you
can still use the app
um maybe it's not as convenient as you
know just sharing it straight from your
console
Xbox share and see how many people has
used that in the past hour
because it tells you on here
like I go to
10 seconds ago 29 seconds ago
48 seconds ago Resident Evil one minute
ago one minute ago two minutes ago two
minutes ago two minutes ago OverWatch
Tom Clancy Tekken all this is free
advertising all of it it's all gone now
if this does do this
three minutes ago like we I just named
like 30 and it's three minutes start
three
like
it's just to me now you're just gonna
have nothing but PlayStation gameplay
constantly going up imagine when like
Spider-Man comes up you know not only do
they hit the the Subways they're gonna
have that popping up on Twitter it's
just like dude it's not a good look I
get it
they probably pay north of 50 000 a
month if that's what Elon was wanting
and I get it it's a lot to ask but first
off
why
I just don't understand why they don't
look at simple things like that and
don't consider them like relevant enough
to keep it maybe they have an issue of
Elon himself and that's why they're
pulling out of the whole company has
nothing to do with money maybe it's Elon
himself and I get that but at that time
are you letting your own personal
agendas not let you push your own
platform
and it's it's sad man but what did you
what's your opinion on this man
yeah see I didn't think about that part
if they use if if they
take away the Xbox share you know like I
said because when I share stuff I would
do it from my from the app
from the Xbox app you know I just share
it
um straight straight from my phone to
Twitter but some people share directly
from their XBox consoles remember how
much
people was upset when they took it away
from the Xbox because I remember they
they made it to where you had to do it
on your phone and people got really
frustrated with that and it's like look
like I get it it could be about money
all you want but guess what dirt mean
you both know
do any of us care if it's about money no
no like it's like kid smooth said you
know I'll read a tweet that kids said
because it he's the reason I found it
kids who let me look up his account real
quick
he said he quote tweeted it and said
hopefully Xbox does more traditional
marketing if they're not going to be
relying on exclusive on uh if not
they're going to be relying exclusivity
exclusively on Word of Mouth which is
bizarre for one of the richest
organizations on the planet
bad look man because the PlayStation's
still dropping those dollars and they
still getting that you know that
connection and those features on Twitter
bad luck man how is fate how is
PlayStation gonna pay the the Twitter
tax for the Xbox eight
yeah yeah see that's why I say that we
can know we gotta wait to see yeah all
of the details with this you know like
more information we'll see because this
is broke like an hour ago yeah but if
that's the case that they don't have the
Xbox share that is a big time issue
because it's about convenience right
when people want to share
a a clip or something happen no I I got
to share this you know you want it to be
as easy as a couple button press you
know you don't want to have to you know
wait until it uploads to your phone then
go to your phone you know so yeah that's
definitely that definitely could be a
potential issue if this is true
yeah and I think I'm just looking at the
the you know the perception look you
know if if you're constantly just seeing
people tweet
oh you know this is this is on Twitter
and it's only PlayStation stuff and you
never see Xbox tweets like that on
Twitter anymore
you know we understand what's going on
because we have our ear to the ground
but there's a lot of people that don't a
lot of people that don't understand
what's going on and they're gonna look
at something like that and be like oh
Xbox just dog [__] I guess because I've
never seen it on Twitter it's never
being tweeted obviously what Dirk says
it's not it's not gonna be the 100 the
case because you can still send it to
your phone oh majority of people got a
smartphone but there's a lot of people
that won't even click off of a video and
go to Twitch
people are very on if I'm right here
right now I'm not going back and doing
it I'm not going to go look for my phone
I'm not doing none of that if I can't do
it from exactly what I'm holding and
it's not going to get posted
and let me say this right quick
you just said how we know certain stuff
and like the casuals don't know I feel
like a game like Hogwarts Legacy the way
Sony marketed that
that's why I think so many PlayStation
units I mean five units were sold last
month because that was a huge game
and like I said the way PlayStation
marketed it
people thought it was an exclusive and
you know Harry Potter is a huge
franchise
and that game moved PlayStations now
imagine the Harry Potter scenario but
now because you see phenomenals all the
time you know Harry Potter was like a
smaller version of what happened to
Eldon ring but imagine if Starfield is
that kind of cat catches that kind of
thing you know there's not going to be
much Twitter Focus going on with the
Xbox now now if you go away from the
first person stuff first party content
we go to like a third party big title
let's say next Call of Duty next Witcher
something that's really going to
gravitate a lot of people and you're
only seeing PlayStation people sharing
it
because we see it all the time people
should share content from their consoles
on PlayStation and Xbox but if you're
only seeing it on PlayStation
I feel like eventually your a narrative
is going to get start forming by that
because that's where the biggest
audience is that's where the people that
you're trying to grab are and now you're
just gone
I just think eventually is it the end of
the world no I will say that this is a
small problem they have but I do feel
like it's like
it's like that little
like you get stabbed by a little pencil
and if you don't treat it it could end
up being something worse
yeah I guess you got a few super chats
so yeah uh let me make sure I don't
double sure okay so
let me get the two lawsuit from bone
slave shout out to attic and dirt always
100 always great content
angry therapist this feels like
everyone's going
to be worst case scenario and look
that's that's why I try to be very you
know transparent with that right now
it's not an issue but I I do think that
you're going to start seeing it's a
domino effect
you know little Timmy on Twitter sees
all his friends tweeting that
PlayStation never Xbox little Timmy gets
in a PlayStation not all little Timmy's
other friends get a PlayStation
you know it's it's about presence and I
do think that really helped Microsoft
keep presence on Twitter to a point is
at the end of the world no but it can
definitely help PlayStation
pull a little bit of you know traffic
that's going on uh that's going on
social media in general
all right five dollar Super Chat from
bone slave Xbox is the social box they
should have Twitter integration like
Discord they have the best party system
as well it's an L in my eyes it is and I
think what makes it worse is if it's
truly just for money
you know because at that point
if I came out there and told you dirt I
can't pay 42 000 a month what are you
gonna say Dirk I get it man that's
expensive
but they're one of the richest companies
in the world can't use that excuse
and I get it maybe it's trying to stick
one to Elon well guess what I have a
funny feeling the PlayStation gonna seed
some of the reactions
and they're gonna keep paying that money
and they're gonna stick it back to you
[Music]
um
unless they have a plan and they have a
tick tock plan or you know a Snapchat
Instagram something like that they might
have a different way of doing it
entirely I don't know I thought you know
I must say on Twitter something about
about lawsuit like he's gonna Sue
Microsoft a good luck with it I mean you
almost got the kind of money to take to
take them to court but is he
realistically going to win probably not
2.300 txx one one three eight so it has
a marketing rights for Hogwarts Legacy
they do and uh yeah they and it worked
bro it worked they they definitely
winged the hell out of that marketing
rights you know you know one thing you
can't say about Sony's they can't say
that they don't have a good marketing
team yeah they do and a lot of it is
because they have stuff to Market it's
like I said like
the issue
hold up next okay the issue with what's
going on is the fact that now
It's Just Gonna Fill one side of when
it's not realistically one-sided it's
just the people that would have tweeted
are low-key be in silenced now and it's
not their fault
uh five dollars from uh gamer by choice
I have a feeling Microsoft is looking at
the long game and think they are better
they are betting PlayStation will not be
the market leader in 10 years Microsoft
will be waiting uh waiting Sony out I
get that but there's a lot of people
that feel that way too A lot of people
feel like they can take on bigger
opponents and wait them out and you know
a smaller opponents and wait them out
well guess what sometimes the other
person's determined
you know and I do want to talk about
that too
I think me and you're going to disagree
with this and I think the chat's
probably going to disagree with this too
all right
let me put it in here
let's see what what we're about to
disagree about Buddy
all right
all right guys
hear me out before people interrupt me
well I mean for you say anything
which you don't really interrupt me so I
don't have to worry about you
only 33 minutes on the dot 33 minutes
do you think Game Pass is becoming a
double-edged sword for Microsoft
no
I think it is so why do you think that
why
I think game passes made it to where
they feel comfortable not pursuing
marketing deals not pursuing
um timed exclusives because they feel
like they can't uh you know getting it
in Game Pass is good enough
I feel like Game Pass in a way has
promoted them to launch games in not the
perfect State because they know they can
fix it later because people aren't
paying for the games at full price
uh is all of them bad no but I do think
wait a minute that that last one
yeah
wait a minute Master Chief Collection
that wasn't a game pass no no I mean it
is now infinite
okay hold on wait but but hold on let me
finish it let me finish let me say this
right quick
you're asking like that's not an
industry thing right now
I feel you
but I do think that
when you see certain things like that
the first thing you hear is what's in
Game Pass I don't care
so I'm not saying that that's like like
if there was a percentage that would be
on the bottom you know what I'm saying
like a percentage of why I think that
but I do think that the biggest ones at
the top is I feel like
they're not being aggressive because
they have game pass because they feel
like they have a long term solution to
anything
I feel like without Game Pass they
probably would have swung for the fences
on certain uh third-party deals and try
to make them second party does I feel
like in in back in the day where they
would have got a game timed exclusive
they're okay with it just being on Game
Pass now they don't push for it to be a
timed exclusive and that's that's my
issue and you know stuff like ghostwire
Tokyo why is that game run better on
PlayStation
why is that okay to a lot of people
because it's in Game Pass and I think
it's not like it's a stigma that game
pass created but I think it's an after
effect of what's been going on I don't
think it's okay to people
well because it's in Game Pass I'm not
talking about the everyone I'm talking
about you know the masses you know what
I'm saying where you know how often
let's be real him we've seen it a few
times where people's like it's okay it's
in Game Pass you know there's a lot of
demographic that feel that way that it's
a game pass I will be able to play it
and when they get fixed they get it
fixed you know I think we're gonna have
to see
something like Starfield how it comes
out and the condition it's in
but it's like I said that's not even my
biggest concern my biggest concern is
the timed exclusives you know back in
the day when they would have had eight
months of no games like their first
party stuff they would have went out and
got a timed exclusive got a a Tomb
Raider like I don't feel like they're
aggressive like that anymore I don't
feel like they really work with people
that much that's not in their little
that's in their stables and look I get
it that is a good thing in a lot of ways
I want them to focus on their first
party because they're never going to
wake up one day and say we're not gonna
work with you anymore but at the same
time
I do feel like timed exclusive is a big
thing and I feel like they keep missing
that I don't know what it is maybe okay
maybe they are going the right way but
for me looking on the outside looking in
I'm seeing your competition has no
problem trying to sit there and snatch
redfall from you trying to snatch
Starfield from you trying to snatch all
the final fantasies from you we don't
know what's going on Square Enix with
the pixel collection but I guarantee you
if you go look at somewhere on there
there's some kind of contract somewhere
in a vault that says you can book this
on anything just not Xbox
they're playing I feel like they are
sidestepping around someone they're
sidestepping with paper and ice when the
other person has a machete
okay
I hear what you're saying this is my
opinion
I could be wrong this is just my opinion
Xbox at right now have bigger fish to
fry than
okay do we want some of these smaller
games to be on Xbox yes of course we do
but I just think right now Xbox focus is
right now they have tunnel vision which
might be unfair to some Xbox fans
they have a Focus right now something
needs to be done
to build up their brand to benefit the
brand
and everything else can kind of wait for
a minute
that's what I think so I I do want to
say I do feel like some of this is the
ABK deal I do feel like they do have
some timed exclusives in their back
pocket but they're not coming out openly
and saying it because the APK though and
I think that PlayStation has the same
stuff going on there is not it's not a
coincidence that we haven't seen
anything from PlayStation in terms of
first party and some big presentation
ever since that deal was made because I
think they value the possibility of
shutting down that deal over valuing the
the presence and media you know calming
some of the PlayStation fans down
because they're you know it's been
pretty tough over there adding and I'm
serious I'm gonna cut you out but now
you just said you think PlayStation
values trying to block the APK deal over
having a showcase yes I do right so if
XBox because to make them feel strong
they're trying to stay away from looking
too strong true but at the same time of
Xbox focus is trying to approve this APK
deal
why are you upset that they're not doing
certain things
but you're okay with PlayStation not
doing certain things about this deal
it's not that I'm okay with PlayStation
doing it I understand why PlayStation's
doing it because they because that Call
of Duty thing real big deal with them
I'm not saying that
Xbox is intentionally doing it because
of ABK I'm saying that that is a factor
in the back of their mind I think that's
one of the reasons they did 12 months
they're like you know we're going to do
the next 12 months because guess what
happens after 12 months dirt the call of
duty deals done next year we'll see you
next year with the big stuff but this
year yeah we got to keep it small we got
to keep it with the small punches and we
got to keep it with mainly the stuff you
already know because it's coming out in
the next 12 months
listen I um I hear what you're saying
but
I think right now it's hard to judge
anything
until this deal is over with as crazy as
that sounds it's hard to judge anything
we just said like you know I literally
just said you know a lot of these
companies are holding stuff back I guess
I'm just looking at especially like the
Japanese market and I'm just looking at
PlayStation like coming out
pretty much undefeated like every time
when it comes to the final fantasies the
forespokens uh the the ronins you know
nine times out of ten there's some kind
of communication right now for from
software to make another exclusive after
Demon Souls I'm looking at all these
games well obviously they make demon so
you get what I'm saying and I'm like
PlayStation got no problem doing the
timed exclusive thing and I'm not I
don't know if it's the reason that
they're doing it I don't know if if
Microsoft's still open working some but
they haven't been able to come to a
middle agreement
but all I'm saying is if it is because
of game passes because they feel
confident in okay we can have a timed
exclusive deal with these people but
maybe having the the timed exclusive and
The Game Pass deal maybe that's too much
maybe it's one of those things where we
don't need to pay as much as we used to
have to pay to have at times exclusive
because having having on Game Pass is
big enough and to a point it is having
your games come out on Game Pass day and
date is a huge thing because you can
Market yourself in all kinds of funny
ways all I'm saying is I just want them
to be more aggressive in these areas I
want to be able to because to me
your studios are good they are but until
you get diverse enough to where you
don't you literally have your sprinkles
and everything you still have to work
with other talent to nurture them so
later on you can do something with them
okay okay let me ask you this out of the
time exclusive deals that PlayStation
has signed so far this generation
name one game that you felt was worth it
timed exclusives that would have been
worth it for Xbox
um I think death Loop was was a good one
for them because I think that death Loop
reviewed very well I don't think Ghost
Rider Tokyo was a very good one
um
I I one could say Final Fantasy 7 remake
Final Fantasy 16 in June
Final Fantasy 16 okay okay that's one
right it's 16 of June Final Fantasy part
two next uh supposedly this year but
realistically next year ronan's coming
out here soon we don't know if Ron is
gonna be good but we know they have good
track records okay
yeah
um I just named like three games I mean
for spoken we don't we don't we don't
talk about spoken but that could have
been a good game now obviously they
backed the wrong horse on that but that
happens sometimes you back the wrong
horse but then there's other things like
Final Fantasy VII remake you back the
good the good one the one that runs and
to me that's my thing it's like
we never would have got a Gears of War
without working with a second party we
never would have got a
um a Bioshock without working with
second party a mass effect without
working with a second party sometimes
your Stables make good games but taking
the risk on other people can sometimes
bring just as much value to your system
oh okay let me I have a comeback they
had to do that back then they didn't
have many studios they they didn't even
own Gears in the Xbox 360 generation
they definitely didn't own Mass Effect
or Bioshock I feel um so what's the
focus now though is owning first party
and sometimes you have to make some
sacrifices it it might not be the
sacrifices that some fans like out here
like you don't like some of the
sacrifices Xbox has made I I I'm not
saying these sacrifices are right I'm
just saying they're necessary
yeah because you're never gonna move on
to a project unless you fix the stuff
you currently have going in and I do
think that they they've done a very good
job at the Japanese Market yeah but it's
just like it's like I said you know they
just got to be a little more aggressive
with that you know take take the the
hell Mary's you know just I guess part
of me too is like
they keep backing stuff especially
marketing wise they're just not paying
out like they backed the last
Battlefield we saw how disastrous that
was
but you see Sony
back in Harry Potter how many consoles
they sell from that stuff Call of Duty
yeah which you know they're probably
about to lose the Call of Duty one but
it's just I see PlayStation not only
backing time exclusive but they back in
good marketing deals too and you know
like we were saying with marketing you
know I personally don't go too much at
the marketing too for Xbox because I
feel like when they have bangers when
they have good games they know who's
going to perform well they they put
money behind it but you can't really
Market some of the stuff they currently
have going because I don't think they're
on the scale I've seen redfall quite a
bit so I aim at redfall and say I expect
that for Starfield probably on a bigger
scale I expect Fable to get something
like that the outer worlds too I do
expect when you start seeing some of
these Studios coming that's why I've
said
I'm at the point where I'm I'm eye clean
you know I'm like I see you Microsoft I
got to see results and I always tell
people because we've seen it over and
over again dirt
we've seen quote-unquote Xbox people
switch over to PlayStation people when
that when when you're going up the
roller coaster finally because for for
years the roller coaster was broke
and finally when we got the track and it
started going up they just jumped off
then for some reason I got to start
seeing some of these games first and
then after I see red Falls Starfield
Fable perfect dark avowed out of Worlds
2 hellblade 2. look how many games I
just named like seven and five seconds
that's a lot of games and if you start
hitting 85 80 and above on majority of
those games and some 90 and above you're
going to start to see a different side
of that argument but until we start
seeing those it's like people always say
the reason PlayStation don't get as much
backlash and get a lot more you know
wait and See's because they have
delivered some games I don't I don't
think all of them you know some people
love to like hype up stuff like uh like
recore not recore uh returnal and I
think you know that's a good game but I
don't think it's like quote-unquote a
banger but you know they just released
God of War like three or four months ago
and those type of games will
when the bad news happens like yo
that sucks but I just played God of War
so you know Spider-Man's coming uh it's
just I think it's just one of those
things where
I do get agree what you're saying I am a
little bit
that's what I'm looking for jumping the
fence I just got to see what these games
start coming out us you know what I'm
saying I mean I mean I mean fair enough
fair enough because they have like you
said you uh named a bunch of announced
games but we don't even know all of the
unannounced games you know they have a
ton of unannounced games also like
what's the policy new games what is the
Coalition working on what's IO
interactive working on is that dragon
game what about NX out you know they
have so many unannounced games also and
you know it's it it's at the point like
okay man I I get it
um PlayStation has marketed some big
third party games Xbox hasn't really
marketed any big third party games yet
um
I just feel that
Xbox first party is going to be
so incredible
there's gonna have so much content
dropping so many games per year
that they're really going to pick it but
I do want them to get a big third-party
game to Market it like a GTA 6 or
something though yeah they they need
those big marks anything I it's like I
told I've been saying for years man
especially talking to Cog like
PlayStation's got this little time this
window
because I think Microsoft spent so long
building the shed
and building all the components in the
shed
that now they're starting to put the
electric to the shed they're starting to
run the uh run the electricity once that
once those circuits are finished
I don't think as long as Microsoft can
make sure that the studios make quality
games to some degree not all of them
have to be bangers but I would say a
decent amount of them have to gauge
people's interest
station keeping up with that demand in
no way shape or form that they don't see
it because what are they doing they're
buying Studios because look you can make
God of War fantastic games chef's kiss
but you know what's more effective than
a God of War
three Horizons zero dawns
you know games that isn't in that 95
that like 85 to an 89 people love people
really have a lot of respect for it sure
it's not that God award it's not that
chef's kiss that game of the year
automatically when you see it not that
that uh that Witcher not that it's
another game man uh that Last of Us Part
Two
but if you get games in the game with
your contender
what's what what do you think looks
better derp you have five games in Game
of the Year one of them is belongs to a
PlayStation that wins game of the year
and four of them belong to Xbox that
don't win game of the year but they're
all game of their contenders
um
I think I mean sure one wins yeah but
having four is actually pretty good
because the best way you can the best
way you can beat a high quality game
like God award is to call up three of
your buddies that aren't as strong as
him but you guys can get it done
yeah we don't need to be crazy we just
all jumping swing on
but I gotta be honest bro I'm I'm a
sports guy right so the reason I'm
saying I'm a sports guy is uh there's
only one Champion though nobody gives a
damn about the four guys that lost
you know maybe the one you know the one
guy that won he's looked at a little bit
differently than the guys that lost you
got a lot of super chats bro yeah I'll
get to them here in a second
that's a that you know I do agree with
you I want those 90 plus those that's
the game of the years all I'm just
saying is
if you have a bunch of really good games
but like maybe one fantastic game every
couple years but you have a lot of
really good games yeah right right those
really good games let's say Microsoft
releases five games one year all of them
are really solid games Sony releases one
to two bangers and one wins game of the
year but the rice guy gave me their
contenders mopped the floor with the
majority of the awards but PlayStation
Got Game of the Year who do you think is
gonna look more peasy like look sure
you're gonna look at God of War you're
like I need a PlayStation to play that
game but you're gonna look at those
other games I need an Xbox to game
though
yeah I got you we got a five dollar
Super Chat man you guys are going crazy
today
okay hold up I gotta go up
yeah because I lost all of them um let
me see how this um soft do what he like
lock him in or something he he copies
and pastes them
oh okay okay I think this is where we
guys were uh Final Super Chat from gamer
by choice I work with software and I can
tell you a lot of companies release
software and mostly completed States and
then patching it later it's not just
Gamepad I show you gamer choice I don't
know the gaming industry like that I
don't know what it takes to develop a
game I'm just telling you that you know
games are definitely getting more Broken
But when I'm seeing a lot of talk on
Twitter that's saying it's okay it's in
Game Pass sure it's not us
you know we most the time keep Microsoft
to the to the grill but when I see a lot
of that conversation I'm using I'm
seeing people just use that as an excuse
uh two dollar Super Chat from Robert
kellett Microsoft got complacent
dangerous when PS right there yeah I
agree find out a superstar from bulk bro
they spent 80 billion on ABK and
Bethesda F times exclusives we own games
and they on Game Pass stop paying the
points four runs 60 frames and it will
be in Game Pass I feel you on that I do
and look I'm not saying to not still go
for the bags I'm just saying
occasionally snatch a bag when you're
driving down the road
uh two dollar super trap from uh TX uh
tx1138 most Publishers are guilty of
incomplete games EA 2K
uh Final Super Chat from cobbweave the
problem is PS market shares make timed
exclusives or marketing those very
expensive for Xbox it cost them 100
million dollars for Tomb Raider that's
the cost of horizon zero Dawn I feel you
on that but I'm not saying to do it a
bunch I'm saying
maybe one every couple years it's a big
caliber game
two uh five dollars from Ed that's 20
zero what's up my dudes keep spitting
these facts
um I'm assuming he's talking about you
because the chat definitely disagreeing
with me uh five dollar Super Chat from
drawing TJ they are not aggressive dude
they are buying Publishers no but that's
not what I'm talking about I'm talking
about going there for you bro you know
you got me a little bit on that one you
know those are homies from wbz2 like
drawing TJ Adidas
okay that is an aggressive move I'll
give you that I just want more of a push
on stuff we're not expecting and and I
think that in the gaming industry when
you watch like the EA moment the E3
moments you want those mic drop moments
and a lot of those mic drop moments have
been timed exclusives yeah two dollars
redfall Starfield Doom Elder Scrolls we
didn't snatch doom doom is still on the
other platform
well the next Doom will probably be
exclusive I think they're done with them
though
really yeah five dollars two track from
bulk uh attic stop acting defeated Xbox
own card Doom Elder Scrolls whole blade
Diablo Starfield forever you sweat and
death Luke call Falcon and Final Fantasy
6 16 time no I'm just bringing up a
point like I really don't care in the
long grand scheme of things I'm just
talking from a perspective of an Xbox
and Playstation gamer it is nice that
they are content I cannot get on
Playstation I get on Xbox
uh bone slave with the five dollar super
abks the people in the office uh problem
ABK is the people in the office problem
how can people cooking in the kitchen
dev's quality of games be affected by
that
ABK is the people okay so he's talking
about Executives and how can cooking in
the kitchen the devs I guess he's
talking about uh
The Game Pass scenario so here it is
like it doesn't matter what the devs
want if they say we want this out by the
19th it's coming out the 19th
so that is them making things like
like for instance redfall they could
have delayed that but there's a bunch of
circumstances and variables and
equations that's leading not to delaying
and it's I guarantee you none of the
devs are saying that I bet you 20 bucks
they would love to put more time into it
yeah absolutely absolutely
uh five dollar super drive from the
Nintendo office the otaku everything
Dirt has said is facts oh God he's
agreeing with you the world's ending
addict is speaking from bias Microsoft
needs to get their house in order before
worrying about other people's house I
feel you on that that's true
that's the good thing when you pop in
and you say yo he's a little bag I want
that game in a year and a half to two
you don't gotta do that you know you got
to go over there and have something you
gotta go there
yeah but I'm talking about those triples
okay
yeah I mean Alexa man they got
like you said they got to fix their own
house first man I feel you on that you
know I will concede to that one you know
uh maybe don't expand until you fix your
own house so I can give you guys that
one I still would like them to do it but
I can get it I got ten dollars by choice
Microsoft spent 69 billion on a
publisher how much more aggressive do we
want them to be they're just not they're
just not fighting like Sony imagine if
they go after another publisher with a
popular IP I feel you on that and I
think they are I don't I don't think
they're done buying buying stuff on
little b-roll if you guys
yeah
you'll be crazy if they are looking at
Sega and they're having Sega buy the
stuff that they want
crazy
you know we want the Angry Birds because
we want this mobile market so go ahead
and buy that because when we buy we're
gonna own it now they want to sell to us
but you know they'll sell to you they
don't know if you're buying you though
right imagine them on Angry Birds and
Candy Crush bro oh my God
okay um
I jumped again all right there we go
we got a five dollar super truck from
Adidas 20-0 wgg in the house
fellow dirt
y it's the homies man they call me so
support man yeah I appreciate you guys I
appreciate you you got to shoot our
Super Chat from Adidas uh 20-0 sorry
wbg in here
who knows you mad bro it's all good you
know what you meant yeah with the
Nintendo Dawn the otaku Roblox exclusive
is bigger than okay I'll give you that
one all right absolutely Roblox
hey yo Donna Taco I know we don't always
agree but uh you right on now side all
day yeah man 20 minutes
boss red 77 was it Microsoft name
publisher of the year in 2021 but oh
yeah boss red The Narrative is Microsoft
doesn't know how to manage their own
Studio some people don't care about
frame rates they just want to see Xbox
burn I agree I think there's a boss red
I'm sorry go ahead I think there's a
vast majority of people that actually
don't want the brand to uh improve they
just want to be able to clown on it to
make money absolutely I agree with you
on that I don't think there's a
Microsoft management issues I think
they're Studio issues there's a
difference between when you have as many
studios that Microsoft has obviously
some of them are going to Rebel some
they aren't going to do what they
supposed to it's easier to manage a like
a 10 team or a five team but Microsoft's
about to hit 30 when they bought uh when
they buy Activision so look I get it
you know they had some layoffs and if
you think about it how much Microsoft
Xbox grew when they bought Bethesda you
would you kind of would have expected a
lot more of a layoff than actually
happen absolutely uh so you know it is
what it is when it comes on that I will
agree with you on that though there is a
lot of people that they don't care how
good they do they just want they just
want the world to burn two dollars super
trap from THX one one three eight that's
the homies TS dirt wbg let's Xbox be
Xbox our own path I I feel you on that
but here's the thing
I've argued with Cog about
they don't need to make
third-person action adventure games I
feel like Microsoft's best bet right now
is to be the king of RPGs because they
have the majority of the studios making
those type of games but it doesn't mean
you can't have some third person action
adventure games
Cognito calls it that just one hashtag
just one two dollar super trap from
gamer by choice Microsoft is making Sony
sell the game stay home
that's funny all right that's
that's I know that kind of derived the
podcast a little bit uh but I was very
curious to hear your opinion on that the
majority of these things really ain't
gonna go too long though we're going to
talk about these
we've had some
some minor leaks of games here okay and
you know let me bring up my Cliff Notes
actually have a little bit of notes when
it comes to this
and notes I mean the videos I made I'm
just gonna click videos and see which
ones I do other zinc the homie other
zinc see people I don't know why people
always forget that gears is third person
yeah but I I think you know
yeah he wants a new IP but to me
You could argue that Coalition is making
some of the best third-person action
adventure games out there luxury they
might not be that type of game that last
episode Uncharted are but they're not
designed to be that type of game right
right all right so all right
it looks like
Exile entertainment
they're working on a new IP uh right
they didn't say new IP it's a an IP
based on a brand popular brand and it
looks like Tango studio is working on a
jrpg uh did you hear about these yes I
did yeah so let's start with Tango
studio because we just saw Hi-Fi Rush
come out huge success I love that game
the game was great you know they make a
jrpg which is very deeded on the Xbox
platform may I add what did your what's
your opinions on this
well I bro two Xbox owned studios are
making new IPS or or well within it in
Exiles uh plates uh case a IP bass so
you say is IP based on
now I say that again for me it's it's
brand based like a popular brand
well no no that's Exile entertainment so
um high five Rush is a new IP that's a
jrpg right right like hang on Gamers
they're making a new yeah so I think
that's dope man um you know I love all
types of games and I think just Xbox
having some brand new IP like a Hi-Fi
Rush brand new IP that's a jrpg that
would be exclusive to Xbox that's
amazing bro that's absolutely amazing
because like guys like you who love Xbox
brand but also love jrpgs I mean that's
perfect for you you know uh you know so
yeah and um as far as in Exile
them so I thought they were doing some
type of Steampunk game so or is there
something separately they're working on
two games
we don't know if one of them is
Wasteland four
so they could be working on a steampunk
game and a new IP that's brand
associated
I'm kind of curious that they're working
on a steampunk game and they said it's
brand socialized what could it be
like I have no idea you know to me
I made a video on it uh people might
disagree but I think the second one
might be a Fallout game
uh because it makes sense it's a brand
yeah
to watch the video but I saw what you
was saying yeah that's the type of games
they make it makes it makes sense now is
it probably happening probably like a 30
70. I'm not putting too much faith into
it it's more of like more like hopes and
dreams but I think it is a possibility
most likely it's gonna be something
random the spin-off you didn't even
think about well
I don't I don't think it's a spin-off um
I think
because if you look at it
it's probably not a game because if they
don't own it
why would that studio let them make it
yeah they don't really own too much
stuff in the the the cyberpunk kind of
error
and I don't think they have really
anything uh so that's not then so if you
go look at movies
there's not a lot of movies you could
think of either they can make something
it's a brand recognition so it means
it's popular to some degree what does
that mean we don't know so to me we
don't know which one's which we don't
know what the the steampunk is a new IP
or is that the brand one we don't know
if the new IPS the brand one or that's
the steampunk one
so I think there's a lot of you know
questions going into that and I think it
would make sense because you know some
people should know is that obsidian I
think Bethesda I don't know no it was
three studies obsidian
Exile entertainment in another Studio
someone in the chat correct me uh they
used to be one company and when they
split up they started uh they pretty
much formed three companies when they
split up right that's where the original
Fallout came from was Exile they made
the original yeah I do remember that
yeah I do remember that and obsidian
made Fallout New Vegas
so
right obsidian definitely made Fallout
New Vegas
um donataku said he heard that the
steampunk is a new IP from what he heard
that's what's up
they were black aisle yeah black aisle
Studio Bethesda was the third one I kind
of figured it was Bethesda yeah I
couldn't remember that's probably why
Bethesda Fallout from them right because
they sell
they saw what they could do with it all
right that's true I you know I did kind
of forget that NSI made the first
Fallout but
it's kind of cool man
I don't you know before we get to the
super chats let's let's go to Hi-Fi Rush
real quick
would you want them to make something
similar to Hi-Fi Rush
or would you want them to make Hi-Fi
like would you want the what's what I'm
looking for would you prefer them to
keep Hi-Fi Rush on the scale it is now
or would you prefer them to like push
more towards like bigger third third uh
AAA
to be honest with you
I'm okay with Hi-Fi Rush being on the
double a scale that it is now because
that's a very high quality yeah it was a
very high polished
very very polished
I'm okay with that listen man at this
point every game doesn't need to be a
AAA we do love these AAA games we do
love the big expensive games but at the
same time every game doesn't have to be
there for every Hi-Fi Rush will have a
hellblade we'll have a star field so
it's okay to have games like Hi-Fi rush
or you know these smaller games drop
like that so I'm okay with high fibroids
remaining like the you know like a high
quality double A yeah so that's pretty
much all comes of that you know let's
let's move on to our final topic man
PlayStation all right home for a second
this niggs guy who is he well you lucky
you ain't on my channel Punk
what's he saying time he's been bashing
that spot the whole time but but it's
all good you know this y'all Channel
he'll be fine nah he's not no I mean
like he's all right
uh let's get these super chats real
quick and then we'll go into that
I know I'm gonna butcher this one coming
up uh but anyway we'll try five dollar
subscribe from uh Nintendo the dawn Taco
bin Studio polymorph
media molecules Japan Studio
Etc have had problems but no one brings
them up when it comes to mismanagement
he's got a point there he doesn't got a
point there
TJ watch Microsoft buy all of Warner
Brother and Sega or Capcom you know what
get two minutes out of those three who
would you want them to buy if you could
pick one of those three who would be
at this point now if you would ask me
this last year I would probably say WB
but now I would say Capcom you want the
yeah
if you'd asked me last year I would have
said WB I'm saying
WB or Sega I don't feel like Capcom
Capcom
helps a lot of their stuff but I don't
feel like
I feel like it doesn't really fix
anything I feel like WB they would have
it people if you come with a superhero
licenses licenses I would say WB then
even if it doesn't they can get a
superhero license they just need the
studio to make it that actually know how
to make that type of game yeah but that
same the
their best superhero Studio they haven't
made a game eight years man that's
something we got to look at oh would you
lost your pen or something no my phone's
ringing I'm looking for it oh one second
someone's called me I don't know who it
is
all right so let me ask you guys because
I mean I would say WB if you can get the
licenses but I just can't
rock star isn't what they used to be
obviously bro they it's been taking them
eight it
Suicide Squad will come out in 2024
Batman Arkham Knight came out in 2015 or
2016 I believe it was 2015. bro
we need to listen man we need to
question what's up with this studio why
is it taking them eight years to make a
game
actually 2024 would be nine years
because Arkham Knight came out of 2015
right guys yeah 2015. and so technically
it'll be nine years
we have to question they're like hold on
uh Rocksteady you guys are really really
good but why are you why is it taking
nine years to make one game
I believe those are questions you have
to ask because even um
Warner Brothers Montreal that made uh
got them nice that game took a while
so what's going on with their Studios
and why are they taking so long
we don't know about the Wonder Woman
game yet but for model if
um but I don't know man
well it's not if you get
WB and you got the licenses that's
that's one I would choose WB then but
just for the studio was at this point I
don't know if I would you know be okay
with that all right sorry about that the
reason I'm saying WB or Sega felt like
Sega Capcom would do it too but I feel
like Capcom
I feel like that's kind of unrealistic
you know like I feel like Sega is the
more realistic thing I think they uh you
know just having Sonic by itself would
be big you would get the the Persona
franchise the Yakuza franchise I feel
like they actually have a lot of content
they can give out shirt and capcom's got
a lot of content No One's Gonna Take
That from them
um but I think they if they got Capcom
it would be a similar thing that's going
on with fact division you know I think
they bought Capcom ftc's like dude it's
Gotta Be multiplayer or you're not
buying like I feel like if they bought
Sega
they'll be like okay you could you could
rock with those that's fine uh W you
think so the reason I say WB is because
I feel like
I feel like they have people to make
hero uh superhero games at least two
Studios because uh Montreal can easily
make one or whatever that studio that
made Shadow avoid Shadow Mordor is uh
you have I'm not a little feeling Wonder
Woman game yeah yeah they're doing
Wonder Woman yeah do you have that you
have uh netherrealm that can finally
make Killer Instinct
even if it doesn't come with Mortal
Kombat which I would really hope that
Microsoft okay you know what combat I
forgot about I forget about another
realm I would choose WB because I forgot
about another round for some reason they
went on the stage and say we bought WB
and not only did we buy WB we're opening
this year
with Mortal Kombat 12 on Game Pass and
it's an XBox exclusive and we're some of
the guest characters this is gonna be
Killer Instinct and they say not only
that
but they're working on a Killer Instinct
game and then when that killer ESC game
comes out they're like next year we're
making a Mortal Kombat versus Killer
Instinct yeah and you know what
disregard what I said because I don't
know why I forgot about another realm I
was just thinking about Rocksteady and
um
WB Montreal I just totally forgot about
Netherland I love Mortal Kombat Mortal
Kombat will come if we'll come as the
Xbox on if you buy the if you buy WB I
believe another realm owned
um Mortal Kombat so yeah I'm definitely
I'm yeah I'll take that back I will get
WB out of those three
from DJ Wars we got 370 people in the
chat man hit that like button let's get
that up man let's get that like button
up you know I don't have any any like
jokes to be making but let's just get
those likes up man hit those like button
uh find out subscribe from DJ Horace
long time listener first time caller
fall guys
I'll play some fall guys with you after
this DJ 5 for call Webb people always
asking where's Xbox's Horizon zero Dawn
God of War or The Last of Us where's
PlayStation's gears Halo or any of the
huge RPGs that are on now on XBox
exclusive of Xbox Live input is very
diverse and I've been very vocal with
that you know you can't go on
PlayStation and have access to something
like Minecraft Legends Halo Wars 2 Forza
Horizon Florida Motorsports I mean you
have a little bit of racing games over
there but not a lot you have first
person shooters RPGs you have a lot of
diversity on the Xbox platform and I've
always gave them well even the First
Quality multiplayer game like first
party multiplayer I know they're about
to have one soon but
no I want them to get Warner Brother and
Capcom ain't no Sega love man he's
completely [__] on Sega right now
but it's okay man it's okay
uh we gotta have a final shoot shot from
Tiz you know what it is
uh give me Batman and I'm good do you
think they should get back on it they
got Warner Brothers do you think Batman
will be the right choice because I don't
I think Batman has been used too much
look Batman would be the good choice but
I think you got something like
Rocksteady you're like you don't have to
make no games as a service make what you
actually make good and you Rave would
get like
you know let's say they can get them
let's say they can get a Marvel IP you
know I don't think that's possible
because I think Sony is blocking Marvel
IPS but let's say they can get a Marvel
IP
they get something like Iron Man or
maybe Captain America
or you know I punish her
Punisher I love that game that was on
the Xbox and the PS2 back love that game
bro what's up fawns I'm just now seeing
you funds I'm so far behind in the chat
but uh yeah I see you guys in the chat
five dollar strip chat from Rhoda
I've heard Saul said that a few times
out of those three you want them to buy
Sega if you want exclusives because if
they if they buy Capcom or Warner
Brothers then games will be multi-plat I
don't think they'd be multiplied if they
bought Warner Brothers Capcom good
chance and maybe not even with Capcom
you know because if you think about it
besides Resident Evil
They Don't Really print out games like
that a whole whole lot you know they do
a very cute
titles but I would say that
I would say Sega puts out more games
than than Capcom that's probably not
true though I don't know I don't really
look at stuff like that I don't look at
capcom's games like that but you're
probably right most likely I would say
Capcom is the biggest
the biggest card we don't know what's
gonna happen with Capcom uh five dollar
Super Chat from uh Jeff one uh zero
jeff1007 Microsoft should buy all Warner
Brother Discovery and Xbox by Sega
that'd be interesting Microsoft buys
Warner Brother and Discovery for like
something they're doing and then Xbox by
Sega but see the funny thing is he's
trying to separate it because it makes
more sense if Microsoft buys it for
their own selfish needs and just like we
don't need these gaming properties you
take them away
oh it's funny that's funny that's funny
I got a good life out of that one man it
keeps jumping
uh yeah
from John TJ with Activision they own
Deadpool oh no no I don't believe they
they published the game I don't think
they own the rice today I wonder if they
have some kind of deal going on where
they make the games kind of like Sony's
got with the the Spider-Man games
yeah I don't know I'm kind of I just
thought they just published it so like
obviously Marvel most likely owns the
games but I wonder if Activision bought
exclusive rights to to make the games
and publish them okay well you remember
because the Spider-Man games in the past
Activision used to publish those yeah
but I think what happened is I think I
think PlayStation used the the Sony uh
the Spider-Man movie rights because
remember they they were going to take
Spider-Man out of the the MCU at one
point yeah they were and I think that's
uh Marvel probably came to some degree
yeah look we're not giving you
everything you want so what do you want
to make this sweeten the dough I
honestly think that my Microsoft can't
make superheroes out of the MCU I don't
think that's a problem I think Sony is
pretty much like look we want Wolverine
and we want to have exclusive rights to
all of the characters and I agree and
people are sitting there say oh MCU
wouldn't know they would Spider-Man is
worth more money yep than you can
imagine
yeah I agree trizz uh you know what it
is Batman the only one that can content
with Spider-Man I agree I'm not going to
disagree with you on that I just think
that
maybe a spawn game I think there's a lot
of different options that you can go
that's not Batman as long as the game on
isn't popular enough though man he's not
popular but if they teamed up and made a
good movie with him on top of the game
yeah you could easily do it but it costs
a lot of money to do that yeah it does
final scripture for the angry therapist
MD give me a Ghost Rider game or
Daredevil Daredevil would be cool I
agree there that would be cool we got a
member chat 41 months that's a long time
by gamer by choice Microsoft could do
something like Marvel Defenders or
annihilators X-Men or Fantastic Four
just something that catches popularity I
agree but once again I don't think they
or have access to that all right let's
let's get into this PlayStation so hold
on hold on you got one more you forgot
about bone Slave oh well you get it I
can read it yeah bone slave of the five
team ninja is a perfect studio for Xbox
Ninja Gaiden dead or alive and wulong
are a great IP team ninja I think it's a
studio they need to buy because I think
team ninja is a small Studio they won't
get any issues with with uh any of these
trade commissions and I think they need
to buy team ninja and then go and buy
Ninja Gaiden and have Ninja Gaiden uh
Team ninja make ninja God
yeah that'd be that'd be sweet if I
missed any super chats dude guys I
really apologize uh things have just
been intense all right so let's get on
to
to this PlayStation Under Fire let me
change the time stamps to 20 minutes
because things have been crazy 20
minutes and 30 seconds
all right so let's let's talk about
PlayStation's starting to get a little
bit of heat on what's going on with
these political things what I find is
funny is do you see some of these
government officials like asking the FTC
you know why you simply like why why
do you think this is okay and we're
trying to con uh to you know encourage
this this acquisition and this merger
not to happen when they're not even
they're not even the the number one
person on the market why are you
defending the number one person on the
market right it's interesting and did
you see that
that the uh some kind of event in Europe
invited Microsoft
to show their products on the day that
the the CMA have before they final
decision their final decision that kind
of makes me feel like they know what's
up they know it's getting approved yeah
yeah man does
um the U.S man they asked her flat they
actually in the car flat out
I'm gonna put it in my my terms not Lena
why in the hell
are you protecting Sony they are the
market leader I think he said she said
68 percent
and you're protecting them
it's from this American company that's
trying to compete why are you doing that
why it hurts why Lena kind why are you
protecting them and her answer was well
uh I don't know what the hell she even
said
she she definitely they they they
weren't going very good man like it's
yeah it's kind of sad because if you
look at it from that kind of standpoint
do they even have a reasoning like they
couldn't they couldn't tell her anything
there's no there's no valid reason why
are you protecting the market leader
I know and you know what's funny lobbies
happen it's like Microsoft was like all
right
we got our own lobbyists some people
educate this woman what to ask her
I love when politicians get asked
questions and they start stuttering
because they don't know yeah they're
like oh well well well if you if you if
if you if you turn to page 365 and look
at section 2A under Section A B you'll
see that I don't know what the hell I'm
talking about right
because she said the FTC how did she put
it
ah man how did she put my uh
lost like what did she say like somebody
didn't chat help me Elena Khan said well
the FTC we believe in
free laws
sodi paid me enough to get elected three
times and I can't go back on though
yeah it's crazy how CR how bad lobbyists
are we just let that [__] yeah the slide
we just let them do it I can't remember
what she said man but
oh man
okay so he pooped I don't know I can't
pronounce your name
but she said um someone said she's the
person uh nothing at the same time let
me get the Super Chat where are you
looking fine I'll just check from your
baby Farva I'm just here to see the ray
tracing Reflections off on my guy dirt's
head and 4K and then 120 come on show
some damn respect God
find out super shot from gamer by choice
I think Sony went scorched Earth because
they know their money hey uh hauling may
be done if Microsoft is willing to spend
billions that was a defense play I agree
I feel like they uh I feel like they're
gonna regret a lot of the things they
did to try to stop this later
um
yep um
okay so she said uh
okay she said the FTC uses facts and law
when making their decisions
yeah so people like guarantee you they
don't know anything about the gaming
industry nothing facts nothing
lost I love when that politician
asked like a couple weeks ago he's like
yo why why do you guys care so much
about Sony and Microsoft is getting
destroyed in their home turf and you
guys ain't do nothing over there to stop
that
look at it it's just little things like
that that I feel
is gonna you know we should all point
to Sony because
for the for the longest time there
wasn't a lot of overstep when it comes
to
when it comes to like the gaming
industry because I felt like
they've let us regulate ourselves for
the most part but I think that's over
now I think they're going to start
keeping more of an eye on the gaming
industry I think I agree because this
you know because of this deal is huge
bro 80 billion like yeah because when it
comes when you get more and more money
then they're like why are they spending
that kind of money
it must be very important right exactly
and if they spend that kind of money why
ain't I getting the piece
there you go yeah 80 billion to make
sure I get the piece in the future
it's just has there ever been a deal
that's this much I don't recall ever
hitting a deal being 70 billion bro I
bet you there is we just don't know I'm
sure there's some oil companies bought
another Oil Company first for for 400
billion before and we just didn't know
because we didn't care right not in the
game I think I think it's I think
there's one other thing that's above
this
in terms of Gaming but I don't I don't
think it was I think it was something
other it wasn't like
it was something different tell me in
the chat
yeah there is a larger acquisition I
don't remember no okay yeah the biggest
publisher in Europe was bought so that's
probably what they're talking about okay
it's just it's crazy dirt it's just
crazy that people feel like
Sony's in the right to some degree in
this
like people feel like the the
I get it there I will say there is
concern and Sony has the right to be
concerned because it's their company and
they have the right to fight for their
company but to me
Fame you can't fight you can't throw
stones and act like you ain't throwing
stones it's like they're cutting their
wrist and they're throwing stones and
when the cops look up they're just
pointing okay he threw the stones well
you have a bunch of stones behind you we
switch places right it's just it's crazy
man it's crazy what do you think when do
you think that's going to be done man
what do you think this this Activision
deal is finally going to get closed I
think it's going to be done by by the
time Microsoft said it would be done
initially they said June 2023
do you think they'll have announcements
to this at their June showing
no I think it's going to strictly that's
strictly gonna be about games or do you
do you think they do something like they
did with Bethesda before the June
showing
and they make an announcement they show
a Diablo trailer and show that in Game
Pass
um
now if the deal is done before the show
I can see them announcing Diablo will be
in Game Pass yeah I I can't see that
yeah
they know for a fact it's getting done
like a couple days before the show
and they open it with buying them
they're like like imagine they come on
there and we want to tell you we know
PlayStation was crying but we're here to
tell you it didn't matter and then the
screen pops up but it's all activated
because we got him in a way
and all the Call of Duty shove all them
are in Game Pass up there you got it
like someone come out in a Crash
Bandicoot suit he's like we're friends
with this dude that's funny now look I
do expect them if the deal is closed
before the Xbox show on June 11th I do
expect them to have an announcement
during the show that all of the all of
the APK games going into game pass on on
a certain date on this day all the
little old Call of Duties are going into
gay pads you know because I do believe
they can put the old Call of Duties and
Game Pass you know that doesn't break
Sony's contract
but it's gonna be fun man yeah we'll
eventually get into um
I do want to do a a prediction show when
is the show the June 11th June 11th so
it was definitely
long it's the 11th what is the Wednesday
before the 11th hold up let me look
June
so we have a June the 11th on a Sunday
so it's an IOP day unfortunately so
that's another five hour podcast for me
um
seven you know we'll do it the 31st the
31st the next month we'll do our
prediction show sounds good to me
brother yeah we do our projection show
the 31st the next month uh we're gonna
go ahead and start closing out man you
know uh we we went into a little bit of
a derail uh I do want to I think we do
have a super chat real quick but I'll
get to that one second we didn't go on a
little bit of a d Row in terms of the
what we was talking about on um
like the Xbox game pass thing
uh so let me go ahead and put the uh
time stamps for the outro which is one
hour and 30 minutes
yeah we usually don't go that long
you gotta think probably 10 minutes of
that was the starting soon screen
uh all right so
let me make sure I get all the super
chats
all right I got five dollar Super Chat
from Anthony Neil I'm happy Sony tried
to stop this acquisition because now
they are under the microscope I would
agree with you they're definitely under
the microscope all right so Dart tell
the people where you're at man what's
going on what what do you got going on
in the next couple weeks on well
well I just dropped a video today about
this Lena Khan uh getting called out by
the US government stuff
um so check it out it was mad spicy
nah it was a short video it was only six
minutes long it wasn't too bad
but um I kind of want to do a um doc man
podcast to talk about
the Doom and Gloom in the Xbox Community
right now I really do want to talk about
that because I just feel certain things
you know I'll talk about it tomorrow I
mentioned some things on on TTS last
week but I feel like certain things
you know I feel that certain
that as a YouTube content creator we
can't ignore and we can't act like the
people in the chat their opinions don't
matter because sometimes these guys like
yeah these blind Xbox Fanboys are mad
because well they have their opinion you
have your opinion I think if everybody
is is respectful it's sometimes you know
you know I do think that some people get
this mindset that the only opinion that
matters is their own yeah and it's like
look I'm just giving you my opinion
sometimes I'll be extra strong act like
you know I do care about people's
opinion but at the same time I don't
because uh I buy my games I will talk
from like a perspective not my own where
I can understand where Activision is a
good deal for place to Microsoft but
it's not a good deal for me because I
don't care about most of their games
right but I do think people need to be a
little bit better with that you can call
me Doom and Gloom that's fine you know
see the thing is is I give their props
all the time so you can call me Doom and
Gloom it doesn't bother me
you know I'm a taxi with you just drop
this chip go there and follow dirt man
I'm serious yeah
that's all you think man yeah uh you
could catch me on uh
on IOP this Sunday uh catch me on the
YouTube channel gaming addict I've been
posting a lot of content on there uh you
know trying to make sure I prioritize
that to some degree and you know I
appreciate it for coming through man
we're going to go and close this out
here I'm sitting over there to fame
entertainment we got a Fame ENT you sit
over there to fame go over there give
him some love man go over there and tell
him addicts and dirt sent you that's
important tell him addicts and dirt sent
you because I got hit I got him he got
to know we got mad love for him he got
to know we supporting go over there and
tell them addict and dirt sent you or
you can say attic show sent you it
doesn't matter to me but I appreciate
her coming through we're gonna see you
next week and this is busy everybody